das ist in diesen zeiten nicht leicht
muslimen zu sein
ich kenne den generalverdacht gegen
muslime aus eigener erfahrung
hassprediger und extremisten beherrschen
das medienbild im zentrum des
misstrauens imame
nun liegt eine alte forderung wieder auf
dem tisch
imame sollen unsere sprache sprechen und
mit den methoden der westlichen
theologie vertraut seien
welcher weg führt dahin sollen schweizer
universitäten islamische studien
anbieten
suchen
ich bin unterwegs zu einer
alteingesessenen bosnischen gemeinde im
herzen der schweiz in emmenbrücke
die bosnier haben ein ehemaliges kino
umgebaut
hinter der unscheinbaren fassade ist ein
schmucker moschee verborgen
freitagmittag zeit des
gemeinschaftsgebiet
ich bin praktizierende muslimin aber in
die moschee gehe ich selten hier sitze
ich auf der frauen empore
doch die ist mit lauter männern besetzt
frauen sind in dieser moschee dennoch
aktiv in der bibliothek finde ich frau
sarrazin schweiz stammen durch
bundespost
jetzt hat der funktion da in der moschee
was machen tätig dh ich unterrichte
gruppe man daher die jüngste gruppe da
sind kindergartenalter und er stieg aus
ungefähr mit graffiti frau
traditionellen und könnten nicht so viel
kritik sie könnte wenn sie möchte ja das
ist nicht verboten
es ist einfach nicht pflicht für frauen
und darum im alter bis platz machen
der imam ist der geistige führer der
gemeinschaft was hat dafür aufgabe weil
ich nicht nur der anbieter der immer
haben ist eigentlich person betreut das
heißt der ganze thema die ganze
gemeinschaft zählen sorge alles mit gott
erst zum imam und dance um sich zu
zeigen
djokovic ist hauptamtlicher imam der
gemeinde
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob alle die
predigt auf das nicht verstehen
koran rezitationen und gebet erfolgen
immer auf arabisch egal wo auf der welt
muslime zusammen beten
ich finde das verbindet und schafft
identität
wir sind gerade zurück von freitagsgebet
sie haben die predigt auf boss nicht
gehalten ich habe nichts verstanden
worum es gegangen in der predigt heutige
thema ist täglicher gewählt das auf
arabisch heißt lamas sehr oft über diese
gebet dass sie sehr wichtig für uns
muslime hin
im alltag sind sie angestellt
während krieg in bosnien
wir sind mit familie jetzt eben der
schweiz gegangen 1993 wenig erinnern sie
sich wie sie überhaupt ihre niemand
damals gefunden haben
sind das konnte geschichte wenn wir die
gründe in unserem verein 1990 war in
nutzen stadt luzern dann zwei jahren
habe eine immer aus der schweiz
engagiert und dann nicht unbedingt
brauchen eine nacht wieder aktiven im
awo hat ausbildung und ich habe ihn
getroffen
das heißt er hat jetzt eine eine feste
anstellung ist ein verstärker stellung
wer hat 23 jahre bei uns arbeiten und
bis jetzt wir sind zufrieden ich zeigen
wir haben ihn werden damals geschichte
dass sie die erstens ersten gesucht wie
man da wir haben drei jahren warten bis
kommt ein entscheid für bewilligung
gewinnen
also das war eine bewegung die sie vom
bund erhalten
oldenburg von günter dann ist sehr
wichtig wenn jedes imam registriert er
bekommt was machen das mit nachher
schwarz arbeiten nicht nur der imam
sondern auch das übrige personal
restaurant und betrieb muss die moschee
verein durch spenden finanzieren will
muss raus geben 30000 franken das seil
wir müssen das zusammen freiwillig das
sei eine große aufgabe ich weiß nicht
wie das und machen weiter und schauen
was passiert wir müssen die junge leute
motivieren
probieren wir deutschlands predigt und
unterrichtssprache finden nicht alle
gleich wichtig die ältere generation
fürchtet den fall aus der heimatlichen
kultur die jüngeren hingegen sehen das
anders sprach die hand legt verstanden
ich für die nächste generation aus dass
das sf bosnisch immer noch predigt wird
ist dieses problem muss die ganze felder
sind ausgebildete imame wovon bosnien
meist oder von kosovo immer wo sitzt
schweiz kommen und diesen tagtäglich mit
der landshut seine und das tut
wer eigentlich unserer agenda
wenn das handy unserer moschee frauen am
friedrich prozent wohl nicht bosnisch
verstellen ob das jetzt mit fragen oder
und das ist gewünscht also das thema das
böse immer mindestens übersetzt dass die
lied wird auch keiner das ja auch ganz
gerne landtags oder geht's nicht
vorstellen dass ein imam news politik
eigentlich eine macht das sensationell
so werden wir natürlich begrüße wilder
wenn apple zum beispiel predigt dann ist
am beste predigt vor die eine
zivilisation der virgin gruppe wuchs das
ist dass muslime die islamische
theologie studieren wohnen müssen dazu
heute ins ausland gehen
als ich studierte gab es in der schweiz
kein solches studienfach
das ändert sich jetzt
genau
freiburg in irland hier in dieser
traditionsreichen katholischen stadt
soll es einen ort geben wo muslime in
zukunft über ihre theologie nachdenken
und forschen können an der universität
entsteht gerade ein zentrum für islam
und gesellschaft
angesagt ist eine lehrveranstaltung über
muslimische und christliche ethik im
vergleich dann würden die heraus
ableiten dass der mensch in beziehung
sogar liebe in beziehung zu gott steht
und das würden sie aus ihrer eigenen
erfahrung heraus
es ist erst die zweite vorlesung des
semesters auf der hand heute werden die
ethischen grundlagen im koran und bibel
vermittelt das interesse am koran ist
groß
dozenten sind die beiden leiter des
neuen zentrums redcoon assist
islamischer theologie
sein kollege hans jörg schmid ist
christlicher theologe und sozialethiker
zwar kann man das wort entweder verletzt
oder vereine lesen und diese pluralität
beizubehalten hatte die schrift
ausgewählt die diese professionalität
stimmt meint wiedergibt herr schmid
gekommen ist gerade aus der vorlesung
mein eindruck war es waren jetzt nicht
viele muslime anwesen ja richtig das
waren zwei muslime anwesend diese
vorlesungen die veranstaltungen die wir
momentan bieten sind ein offenes angebot
also es gibt noch keinen eigenen
studiengang sind teilnehmer jetzt aus
der theologischen aus der
philosophischen fakultät die einfach
auch mal ihre kenntnis jetzt in bezug
auf islam und dialog vertiefen möchten
haben sich auch schon immer angemeldet
also vielleicht nur noch um das auch
klarzustellen es gibt ganz verschiedene
zielgruppen in der weiterbildung
natürlich sind die maler auch eine
zielgruppe aber auch wenn man auf
muslimische gemeinden klickt gibt es
leiterin von frauen gucken
vereinsvorstände jugendleiter und so
weiter also wir wollen da dem klick ein
bisschen weit hinter sich oftmals sehr
auf die imame verengt was jetzt die
imame selbst auch betrifft ist die
situation so dass sie vor ganz ganz
hohen erwartungen und anforderungen
stehen sie haben das bedürfnis auch über
diese rolle nachzudenken und sich zu
stärken
und dann gibt es natürlich das interesse
sich in einzelthemen wie jugendarbeit
oder auch prävention gegen
radikalisierungen vielen anderen auch
noch mal vertieft zu qualifizieren die
kunden das was bedeutet es hier islam im
wissenschaftlichen kontext zu studieren
dann ist ein wichtiger schritt um zu
zeigen dass die schweiz eine eine
plurale gesellschaft ist und weil den
muslimen auch möglich die möglichkeit
gegeben wird auf eine plattform zu
errichten wo sie über den eigenen
glauben auch wissenschaftliche mit nach
wissenschaftlichen kriterien
reflektieren können hinterfragen können
und sich überhaupt fragen können was
mache ich was glaube ich wie so glaube
ich dass und wohin gehe ich
und wenn sich muss immer die frage
stellen können und lösungen anbieten
können entsteht auch ein dialog den ich
nur auf vorurteilen besteht sondern auf
fundiertem wissen von beginn weg blies
den neuen zentrum ein rauer wind
entgegen
islam an schweizer universitäten ist ein
reizthema in freiburg hat die svp eine
kantonale initiative gegen die eröffnung
lanciert ihr wortführer manuel weber
findet es falsch den islam an der
hochschule mit einem eigenen zentrum zu
privilegieren konkrete gedanken zentrum
wie wir bei bedarf sei für islam es
spezielles zentrums gründer von
klarmobil.de ganz birte will ihnen
hauptuniversität bestehende strukturen
innerhalb von der theologische abo
innerhalb von der juristischen fakultät
möglichkeit die islams bildbände und
somit bessere verständigung mit anderen
religionen zu einem granatsplitter name
in der schweiz bilden oftmals im ausland
macht in der türkei in saudi arabien
anderen ländern finden sie das richtig
gut da muss ich sagen dass du diversität
klarheit und das staatsradio dass die
mammuts bildet ab otto wird dass sie
schon richtige sollten aber lang genug
in der politik und hand erfahre dass
nach salamitaktik das völlig eine zweite
schritt könnte stattfinden was ist genau
eine initiative lanciert an das ziel für
die initiative ist eine staatlich
finanzierte ausbildung von islam
universität wo anders sieht so das klima
muss billiger universität stattfinden
initiative hat wenig chancen zur
abstimmung zu kommen
ihr wird vorgeworfen diskriminieren zu
sein und gegen die hochschulautonomie zu
verstoßen
durch die universität nimmt die bedenken
ernst ja ich denke mal es ist ganz
normal wenn etwas neues da ist dass das
fragen hervorruft und das thema islam
auch weltweit ist ein thema was die
menschen sehr beschäftigt und was mit
ängsten verbunden ist aber ich denke wir
können hier zeigen dass hier eine
diskussion gestartet würde die die
vielfältig ist die interdisziplinär ist
wir sind ein interfakultäre zentrum
hier etwas was öffentlich ist da kann
man hingehen da braucht man keine angst
davor zu haben und ich denke das ist auf
jeden fall die bessere alternative als
solche diskussionen in ganz
geschlossenen räumen auch zu führen oder
sie nur ins ausland zu verlagern
unter den muslimen in der schweiz
dominieren gemeinden aus dem balkan und
der türkei
die meisten sind sunniten schiitische
moscheen gibt es nur wenige
natalia davis hat vor acht jahren zum
islam konvertierte mann stammt aus dem
libanon zweimal zu lassen
die gewählte innerhalb vom islam
minderheit sind also minderheit in der
minderheit und die muslime in der
schweiz grosse hingeknallt kinder geht
muss zahlen
sie ist sehr schlicht nur luzern sondern
wirklich zentralschweizer kontinente
ozean obwohl der nichtwahl der uri
schwyz motor sind und vielleicht 20 bis
30 familien oder weniger
ich weiß es nicht man rede wenn vierte
gehe ich wieder im ramadan ist es vor
dass im schlaf zwischen 80 und 100 liegt
und er leitet jetzt die client insgesamt
also mehr hängt kein fixer imams der
moschee oder im gebetsraum ist endlich
eigentlicher moschee hinter sich zuzieht
im ramadan vor allem und wenn es gleich
weitergeht über wochen dass im libanon
der wirtschaft immer wichtiger jahr
endlich klarheit er geht also arbeit im
jahr und den ist der beitrag darüber
mutter natürlich zwei wochen oder so
lange wie möglich ist oder noch länger
worden ist meint leitet aber apple fixe
mir nicht und uni fribourg gesetzt das
zentrum für islam und gesellschaft wir
sehen die bestrahlung gedauert
ich habe dir im august bilder also
grundsätzlich denke ich ist es gut wenn
ihre schwimmer muss bildet
aber das ist mir ganz gut gelungen und
gut auf gleise
das heißt wer es was es einmal war sind
überhaupt die prozente wurde immer und
den ausbildern was für eine ausbildung
und was für den doktor ihren kapitän
oder was für eine islam für profitieren
das war ganz wichtig und ab mir
persönlich meine ist dass das vielleicht
früher ist sondern dass das etwas für
die nächste generation ist sie
befürchtet dass das eigene schiitische
islam verständnis zu kurz kommt bedenken
die ich auch in anderen gemeinden
gespült haben lehren sie hier
also ich möchte betonen dass es nicht
nur eine art islam gelehrt wird sondern
wir versuchen zumindest mein anspruch
ist es zu zeigen dass es
unterschiedliche verständnis
unterschiedliche ansätze innerhalb der
islamischen tradition selbst es gibt
dabei ist wichtig dieser traditions-
bezug für mich selbst dass es aus seiner
gewalt zu zeigen dass das auch einer
gewissen tradition kommt und auch
möglicherweise eine aktualisierungs
potenzial hinzuweisen zu sagen das war
bisher zwar der fall aber es gibt auch
möglichkeiten es heute anders zu machen
und wie berücksichtigen sie jetzt
unterschiedliche islamische
denkrichtungen traditionen die
historisch begründet sind also
schiitischen islam sunnitischen islam in
verschiedener ausprägung ich sehe sie
alle als gleichberechtigt tränen nicht
zwischen richtigem oder falsch im islam
sondern ich würde zeigen zum beispiel zu
einer gewissen frage möchten sagen in
der sunnitischen tradition gibt es dazu
45 ansätze in der schiitischen trotzdem
vielleicht genauso viele oder wenige
dass ich dann versuche so gut es geht
darzustellen wie man auf diese lösung
gekommen ist oder wie man auf diese
gedanken gekommen ist und dann überlasse
ich die entscheidungen den studierenden
natürlich heißt dass sie verstehen das
angebot auch zur glaubensvertiefung der
muslime die hier studieren oder
eigentlich zu einer eher zu einer
distanzierten
weder noch das ist glaube ich eine
persönliche sache die jeder selbst
entscheiden muss hier das wird ein ort
sein wenn sie die islamisch
theologischen studien etabliert sind wo
man das handwerkzeug dafür erlernt zu
hinterfragen was tue ich und was mache
ich auch jemand das dafür nutzt es den
glauben zu vertiefen oder sie sich noch
stärker davon zu distanzieren das ist
etwas was die wissenschaft nicht steuern
sollte meiner meinung nach dem
dreispitzareal in basel steht das größte
türkische gebetshaus der schweiz
es wird vom türkischen staat
mitfinanziert an freitagen treffen sich
hier bis 400 musliminnen und muslimen
vor dem gebet sitzen die männer in der
moschee kantine zusammen
im ratssaal wie ist von der staatlichen
türkischen religionsbehörde diyanet
angestellt und bezieht von dort auch
seinen lohn sowie derzeit 36 weitere
türkische imame in verschiedenen
moscheen der schweiz der frauen raum
nicht abgetrennt neben dem gebetsraum
für männer kurz vor dem freitagsgebet
sind die musliminnen in arabisch studium
vertieft
ich bin gespannt auf die angekündigte
predigt das deutsche lautsprecher
überträgt die worte des imams
zum gespräch nach dem gebet bleiben wir
in der moschee ich behalte meinen kopf
durch an der hand charité schaffet führt
janyk
die türkische religionsbehörde was
müssen immer am komitee in der schweiz
praktiziert also schweiz hätte die eu
flagge und diane zaubert natürlich heute
im schlager bevor sie im armen center
soll das wäre natürlich das
theologiestudium muss abgeschlossen
haben dass er mindestens acht jahren mit
sich bringt und diejenigen westerwald
warten müssen ein sprachkurs besuchen
und das seminar das 14 tägige seminar
russland stellte vorbereitet und was
stellt schweiz verbringen
die sieger wurden zusammengestellt das
sie mindestens sps sprachzertifikat
müssen mit sich bringen
falls das nicht der fall ist bietet er
ist ein integrations für die barrick
abschließt die dankeskarte wird aber das
sprachzertifikat bei ace vollbringen
trifft das jetzt im fall von ihrer
moschee zu so zuerst hätten bereits vor
fünf jahren erworben
das sind deutschkenntnisse natürlich ist
es nicht alltäglich
demnach stieß besucher die kursbesucher
um das wieder aufzufrischen ist das
problematisch winkel namen
fremdfinanziert war von einer
ausländischen behörde
das problematisch finanziell ist es ja
neue und univ ebook das zentrum für
islam und gesellschaft wie stolz die an
die türkische religionsbehörde zu dem
projekt es ist eine sehr positive genug
gestellt
natürlich wenn man
islamisch-theologische studios in der
islamischen perspektive darstellen
das doktoratsprogramm wo jetzt aber ab
heute wird bietet natürlich keine
alternative von der im auswärtigen amt
sind
aber ich es dankbar dass die imame vor
denen jetzt dreht ist dass man die
entweder bilder geschickt die
altersweise für die möglichkeit heißt
das wenn sie hier es theologiestudium
wird gar würdet ihr türkischen
jugendlichen im news-interview sich das
theologische das ist genau was das ja
wort gab ist man natürlich nicht auf
dass zurückgriffen
bz was war amerika auf die mama von muss
landtag wissen im moment ist es so sie
dass länder wie die türkei oder saudi
arabien hiesige moscheen mitfinanzieren
ist heute etwas 9 prozent ist basel die
stadt mit dem höchsten anteil an
muslimen in der schweiz
viele von ihnen leben in kleinbasel die
stadtregierung bemüht sich intensiv um
das zusammenleben
es gibt einen runden tisch der
religionen und sogar eine koordinatorin
für religionsfragen und es erstaunliche
integrativ zu wirken wie heute nicht
eines sitz von links bis rechts weg von
der hinterhof moschee man sich die
muslime unterstützen und so weiter und
jeder schritt für mehr qualität für mehr
ausbildung für bessere strukturen durch
mal wieder bremens oktober bin ich ganz
klar der meinung dass mir sehr wohl eher
ganze stark sehr starker bedarf haben am
integrationskurs mir von staatlicher
seite haben wir in unserer bieterkreis
ist es richtig und nötig dass der staat
glaubensgemeinschaft kontrolliert das
ist just widerspruch wir im moment sehr
klar spüren sind genau in der phase mit
debatten rund um sogenannte
dschihadismus ich würde
präziser formulieren religiös begründet
die radikalisierung der handelsplatz
klar es vor nach mehr kontrolle mehr
sicherheit und auf der anderen seite
erklimmen und die position des rother
stark wie viel in den stadtbus und wir
sind ja gestellt
sie sind alle mit einer nuss namen für
ihren verein abstellt dass in so
genannte free thiemann oder laien immer
und wir können anderen aber noch mehr
haben wenig über wirklich toll sie mal
durchlaufen und aufgestellt sind um mit
denen jetzt kann thomas stadt eine
integrationsvereinbarung das ist eine
sicht die türkische band türkische staat
bezahlt
und jetzt gefordert dass die
integrations fribourg das heißt dass sie
lieber b1 können dass sie eine
qualifizierte ausbildung und
verständliche zukunftsmusik vorstellt
wohl schon zukunft ist dass sie so immer
als billige löhne machen für mehr ganze
wertvollen zwischenschritt ist das
allgemeine präsident der jugendliche was
sich engagieren frauen verantwortlich
dass die zumindest wieder bilden könne
mache
im basler entwicklungsgebiet des
dreispitz areal sind mehrere
gebetshäuser angesiedelt hier gibt es
noch platz für ritual räume
muslime aber auch hindus und christliche
migrationsgruppen verändern die städte
und agglomerationen
noch ist nicht ausgehandelt welchen
platz diese gemeinschaften in der
schweiz haben sollen
das zeigt auch der streit um die
ausbildung von imamen kann das zentrum
der integration des islams als ganzes in
der gesellschaft beitragen
es gibt viele orte und institutionen wo
das zusammenleben mit muslimen
eigentlich jetzt schon gut gelingt es
ist auch unsere aufgabe solche gelegenen
beispiele sichtbar zu machen und dort
auch zu helfen wo es einfach viele
fragen gibt das ist zum beispiel in
gefängnissen der fall oder es ist in
spitälern der fall es gibt konflikte in
schulen bekleidungsvorschriften
speisevorschriften wie kann man damit
umgehen vor allem auch angesichts dessen
dass es eben nicht den islam gibt
sondern der ganze vielfalt von
auslegungen und die menschen doch
zusammenleben müssen
zum abschluss lädt mich die täter seien
in der bosnischen moschee ihren
religionsunterricht für die kleinen zu
besuchen
der integration verlangt kommt an den
moscheen nicht vorbei das thema ist sehr
sensibel weil es an der prekären
schnittstelle zwischen staat und
religion liegt und weil der
religionsfrieden ebenso wichtig ist wie
die religionsfreiheit
es geht um mehr als um die ausbildung
von imamen die moscheen brauchen gut
geschulte und mit der schweiz vertraute
betreuungspersonen denn hier wachsen die
muslime von morgen heran